NASCAR's first ever Chicago street race
began with excited anticipation I'm
living the dream as American hero
getting no better place no better no
better day no better City this is it
50 000 fans came from California to New
York and every state in between so I'm
I'm all the way up I'm highly excited
I'm a big Nascar fan Elliott
drivers traversed Chicago's downtown
streets transformed into a Racecourse
with 12 turns eight of them it's Sharp
90 degree angles definitely treacherous
on you know one mistake and you will hop
too much and you're going to be in the
fence
engines boomed and race fans swooned all
right this is my first NASCAR race then
the first of two races 175 kilometer
circuit on Saturday was stopped in
progress due to lightning
Sunday began with what the National
Weather Service called life-threatening
flash flood conditions unfortunate day
that it's super rainy and foggy but I
think we're gonna weigh it out and they
did wait for hours on Sunday NASCAR
called The Unfinished Saturday race for
Cole Custer who was in the lead when it
was stopped two concerts were canceled
for rain but as they say the show must
go on and it did go nastar fans who'd
given up rushed back to Grant Park to
watch the on-again off-again race the
adversity and everything else that they
have is the smartest thing they've ever
done as far as I'm concerned because you
have people that didn't even know about
the sport and now they do and it's
Chicago and you're excited about it
absolutely
despite the delays and event
cancellations city leaders hope the
biggest winner of the weekend is Chicago
with an estimated economic impact of 113
million dollars and a few newly paved
streets John hendren Al Jazeera Chicago